mature stx les gens dans la rue en
espérant qu'ils le reconnaissent eux lui
demande des selfs isource et bien au
genre ton alors en fait un jeu que je
suis allé boire un café sur les
champs-elysées ouais et pendant une
heure j'ai assisté un triste spectacle
ouais le vil matthieu delormeau en train
de faire des allers-retours sur les
champs donc les gens le reconnaissent
ils font des scènes qui n'ont fait cette
fois l'aller-retour sur les champs et
nos regards bayh avait deux trois photos
et c'était pas ou ne devait plus quelle
affaire pour devrait donc non c'est ici
qu'est ce que tu veux les allers retours
sur les champs ces parades que je fais
de temps en temps cette affaire mme de
tandt en gt2 petit test de popularité
voilà je regarde à tout petit peu
effectivement quand je marche sur une
avenue combien de personnes vont
m'arrêter pour me parler quand je vois
que ça descend un petit peu je remonte
le long des missions et voilà c'est
parce que j'avais des gens et je pense
qu'il m'aime aussi de tout ça vous
l'avez jamais fait vous avez jamais vous
balader sur une avenue en croisant les
gens pour voir combien on faire de photo
numérique
et vous êtes-vous jamais quelques mois
alors il s'appelle